[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american science fiction
action film called surrogates spoilers
ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in a futuristic world the field of
robotic science has been highly
developed mankind manufactures an
artificial life form called the
surrogate the surrogates are realistic
looking robots that are linked to
people's brains they are connected to
the brains with a device that has more
than a hundred sensors when a human is
seated on a chair-like device those
sensors attach to different parts of the
human brain by this process whatever the
human thinks of the surrogate does
officials describe it as controlling
your second body through your brain the
inventor of the surrogate lionel cantor
made it to help disabled people live
life as normal human beings
however only three years later it starts
to be used in wars to strengthen the
military as more devices are
manufactured they become cheap enough to
be bought by the general public this
event changes the course of human life
people begin using their surrogates to
go outside their homes and eventually
they become fully dependent on it
because of the surrogate you can go out
without having to physically leave the
house which minimizes the risk of
accidents robberies and diseases
moreover you can look however you like
without having to go through plastic
surgery or exercise the surrogate will
be the new you and will interact with
the people of your life while you
control it from your home only seven
years after the invention the largest
surrogate company named vsi released a
statement saying that currently 98 of
the world population uses surrogates in
different aspects of their lives humans
live in near-total isolation rarely
leaving the comfort of their homes their
surrogates interact with other people's
surrogates which has become the fashion
of life now because of the use of
surrogates violent crimes communicable
diseases and discrimination decrease to
a record low
however not everyone is fond of this
technology there is a minority group
that believes that humans are not
supposed to live through machines they
have established surrogate-free zones in
different parts of the u.s and are led
by a man widely known as the prophet it
is now 14 years after the invention of
surrogates a young man is on his way to
a club he lies to his dad on the phone
saying that he is about to go see an
opera at the club he jumps off from a
balcony but lands safely suggesting that
the guy is a surrogate he meets a girl
while dancing and brings her out as the
two make out a man on a motorbike uses a
device on the two to kill them when the
paramedics and police arrive they find
out that the guy surrogate's memory chip
is completely fried so they cannot find
his registered owner however the girl
surrogate is registered by the name of
cameron mcallister two fbi agents named
tom greer and jennifer peters find
cameron's address and visit her when
they reach the house they find out that
cameron is actually a middle-aged man
who has been killed while sitting on his
surrogate linking device this is the
first murder in years so the detectives
are shocked the scene cuts to a running
subway tom is returning home from work
and we see everyone around him is a
surrogate when he reaches home he brings
water for the real hymn who looks vastly
different the real tom has been using
his handsome and young looking surrogate
to live his life for him after putting
the surrogate to his station tom walks
out of his room to meet his wife maggie
but instead he is greeted by maggie's
surrogate tom hasn't seen his wife in a
long time and only talks to her
surrogate tom suggests they go for a
vacation somewhere but maggie would
rather send her surrogate for vacation
and experience life through her
somewhere else some teenagers find their
friend jared cantor dead in his dorm
room while still on his stim chair at
the fbi office the detectives are
discussing the case they figure that
whatever device the surrogates were
killed with killed their owners as well
such a case was deemed impossible till
then because the owners are not supposed
to feel what surrogates feel
they find out that jared was the son of
dr lionel cantor the inventor of
surrogates tom and jennifer make an
appointment with dr cantor and go to
meet his surrogate they figure out that
cantor has been using several surrogates
at a time which is considered illegal
however since he is the inventor the
detectives dismiss it jared was using
one of cantor's surrogates when he got
killed this makes the detectives believe
that the killer was after cantor not
jared
they then go to the largest surrogate
manufacturing company vsi headquarters
to investigate but the ceo dismisses
them claiming that the surrogates are
100 safe to their owners by the camera
footage embedded in jared's surrogate
when he was killed they find the picture
of the man who killed him they go to a
colleague named bobby saunders who is an
administrator of the fbi computer system
he figures jared's killer's name is
miles strickland bobby also has access
to every single surrogate in the u.s and
can turn them off at any time after
finding miles location tom and a
colleague pursue him on a helicopter
however as they are about to get him
miles flashes all the detectives with
the weapon killing both the surrogates
and the operator he also harms the real
tom and kills his friend their
helicopter crashes in a restricted area
filled with anti-surrogates before tom
can get the killer his surrogate is
killed by the anti-surrogates the real
tom is injured because of the weapon he
walks out of his room and falls
unconscious
then we see miles meet the leader of the
anti-surrogates the prophet who asks him
what he told tom miles insists that he
didn't reveal any information but the
prophet kills him anyway
tom wakes up in the hospital where he
finds out he has been suspended for a
week for landing onto the restricted
area however he is determined to solve
the case so he goes outdoors without the
surrogate for the first time in years he
then goes to the restricted area to meet
miles again but comes across his body
being cremated tom asks the prophet
about the weapon miles used earlier but
he claims he has never seen one the
prophet's men realize he is a cop and
beat him tom gets out of the restricted
area when a young man offers him a ride
home turns out the man is cantor's
surrogate he asks tom about jared's
murder case cantor advises tom to focus
on the weapon and where it came from
when an injured tom reaches home he sees
maggie with her young friends hanging
out in the living room maggie gets
nervous when she sees him but he doesn't
confront her
later tom sees her talking to a man and
beats him but the man is a surrogate so
it doesn't bother him in the following
scene we see a man break into jennifer's
house and kill her right after he takes
control of her surrogate the following
day tom visits the military general and
asks him about the weapon the general
informs him that the weapon is called an
overload device it was made as a war
weapon to bug the surrogates with a
software virus however the officials
didn't know that the virus would kill
the operators as well after they figured
it out the manufacture of the weapons
was ceased
vsi was the manufacturer of the weapon
and they destroyed every unit of it
however this one weapon was left out in
exchange for the information tom tells
them that the restricted area has the
weapon
then we see the prophet hand his men the
weapon to deliver it to jennifer's
surrogate tom then goes to maggie's work
and asks her if she misses their son
it turns out that the two had lost their
son in a car accident and maggie has not
been able to recover since we get a
glimpse of her real self who is old and
wrinkly a total opposite of her
surrogate she and tom are still grieving
the loss of their child
somewhere else the military attacks the
prophet and his men to get the weapon
back from them however when they shoot
the prophet who is the leader of the
anti-surrogates they find out that he is
also a surrogate the scene cuts to dr
cantor on his computer monitoring the
person in front of the prophet we get to
know that cantor was the one posing as
the prophet to stop the use of his own
invention tom meets jennifer's surrogate
who is now being controlled by cantor
she tells tom that cantor's son was
killed by vsi and their boss andy stone
they had figured out that cantor was
trying to stop the use of surrogates
which would cause vsi a huge loss
therefore they along with stone planned
to kill canter with the weapon however
they killed his son mistakenly carter
couldn't bear the thought of his son
dying and made it his mission to kill
all the people using surrogates however
he needs the weapon and a code to make
it function jennifer already has the
weapon she tells tom that stone was
involved to kill jared and asks him to
bring stone's computer file to her as
evidence
tom goes to meet stone and knocks him
out he then downloads everything from
stone's computer and rushes out now that
jennifer finally has the weapon and the
code she has to go to bobby to induce
the virus through the weapon to every
surrogate in the world
tom realizes that jennifer's surrogate
has been taken over but just then they
get into an accident
jennifer runs to bobby while tom rushes
to the root of the problem cantor
jennifer holds bobby at gunpoint and
induces the virus into the system in a
few minutes everyone with a surrogate
will die
just then tom reaches cantor's mansion
and asks him why he is doing all this
cantor replies that he had made the
surrogates to help handicapped people
not for everyone to be dependent on it
now that his son is dead he doesn't want
to let his death go in vain and wants to
end the surrogate addiction
after laying out his reasons cantor
takes a pill and kills himself
tom takes over jennifer's surrogate and
asks bobby how he can stop the virus
from spreading
bobby quickly tells him the codes and
the two successfully saved the
surrogate's operator now tom has to
click yes to save all the surrogates he
hesitates as bobby tells him they only
have a few seconds left
he finally presses no disabling all the
surrogates in the world we see hundreds
of surrogates stop working in the street
soon their owners come out of their home
for the first time in years tom rushes
back to his home to see the real maggie
is not in her room he finds her in their
son's bedroom and the movie ends as the
two hug
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel